[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going bros my name is peter pan
today is a special occasion because it's
my 69th number reddit video I never
thought we would make it this is so epic
so as popular request we're gonna review
our slash nice excuse me be quiet
cheats s problem with this subreddit is
that it's not that funny
I mean random number between 69 and 666
420 I mean that's epic I'm not gonna lie
but it's kind of like the same actually
let me let me give it a shot let me give
it in Interstate 70 has a mile marker
for nineteen ninety nine cents mile
marker 420 kept getting stolen okay
that's nice
alright maybe this is funny how about
that the current version of Firefox is
69 nice right did you just understand it
did you understand me he said the epic
number big chunker's moment right there
if pi is infinite then somewhere in
there there's 69 420 something that
keeps me awake at night
CPI inflation calculator okay 69 1940
has the same buying power for 20 Wow
alright see yeah it's the same joke over
and over again there's another subreddit
that I wanted to reduce Dave sent me
this it's called game physics gone wild
and here we have the Last of Us these
rogue physics are so good so they had
it's actually kind of cool I never seen
this in a game before where you have a
rope that you can throw around it is a
bit wonky those I expect there to be
wonky versions for people online alright
let's watch this ok you're not supposed
to throw the rope there by the way oh no
what are you doing oh god what's gonna
happen I want to try this next time
I'll try this I mean that's just cool
there's no there's no era it's just cool
oh my god I expected something like
crazy to happen like the whole building
flying off worth
no no what a buzzkill
what the hell all right what do we got
I'm working on a system for picking up
physics obviates it's going really well
okay grab your box
[Laughter]
nice hey I did the meme I did the name I
said nice oh god these games are always
so oh my god he's beginning to believe
my fears my fears jay says cries oh the
special attack mode it's going through
the sale a love it or hate it this is
what peak and physical combat looks like
Wow battlefield one Oh God
sinking ship comes back okay ship
explode epic rest in peace everyone put
F in the chat Jason she says Christ
that's terrifying someone said my name
hey go her you were talking sick girl
half-life alex has physics good enough
to juggle yeah that was cool so it's not
all this really bad ones
whoa that was an underrated game I'm
surprised more people gonna get into
that that's so cool I like that it's not
all just funny ha ha um even though I'm
very disappointed in the Last of Us wait
I'm thirsty sick as a dying light some
multiplayer or what I can't tell I'm not
a gamer I can't earn donors saying all
right gang base flawless physics
everyone know this whoa that's
impressive
damn go I don't mean to shell for my own
games but if you like physics and games
check out just died already
the demos out link in the description
okay cut time it's fancy play this last
of us to leaked footage that's what I'm
gonna do the Debbie as soon as I find
out Debbie sorry her name is Debbie I
keep forgetting
Mad Max max has a very poor situational
awareness or great or great thanks EA EA
games never have any glitches in them
yeah uh here we go I got the ball I got
done everybody Assassin's Creed Black
Flag Ubisoft never had glitches - oh wow
oh no they're dying seven saved them
whoa
oh yeah he's the chosen one been
returning through their homeland
hey it's 2020 anything can happen am I
right gamers whoa oh my god Wow Wow
someone expect that I love it Formula 1
2017 this is not real is it no no it
definitely isn't real is it real so you
barrel rolls ahead of him makes him flip
i legit can't tell if this is a video
game or not is that weird and mice
stupid I mean I am but come on yeah it's
clearly a better game they wouldn't
flick with that sort of weight it just
wouldn't happen plus you can see the
underneath of it has just a black canvas
I'm kind of a genius so I can tell it's
fake but it does look look at the bottom
now look at that yeah no way I'm very
smart
basically I'm my brain huge all right
well I - another flawless game but
that's that makes perfect games at all
times
the suspense in this clip is killing me
[Laughter]
so long [ __ ]
Pub G another flawless game no not the
bridge a alternate universe things could
have been different
you keep driving oh my gosh he's the
chosen one they wave at the end - oh my
god Rainbow six you'd be stopped not the
flawless game giving birth be like flip
this is real oh my god this is real your
pant footage okay
new world record one jump man one jump
man whoa he's not gonna fit oh oh
fly away come fly let's fly with me I've
seen it all
nice imagine if the real world were like
this it would be so epic you know the
world lucinda simulation because but
that said then had programming that was
not bethesda game i mean you miss a--
all right what do we got what game is
this cod World War 2 yeah when people
realize life is a simulation and they
can glitch it that'd be so epic
then what if the world is assimilation
and everything an abnormal or surreal or
ghostly is this glitches kinda like deja
boo' oh my god matrix already explore
that what
no way someone made co-op in Polly
braids
why make bridge when bridge can walk
itself is the truck inside it no way no
way no way dude holy ah we came so close
that is seriously impressive hello games
like Oh God
Oh No yet again what are you doing stop
babe that's me writing Jurgen screaming
gold in Minecraft oh the WWE games the
most perfect games of all time never any
glitches whoa what do you think is gonna
happen you never know come on judge you
can do it don't do your dance spider-man
can't swim hold my beer oh my god the
NBA games yes whoa No oh my god
your game ten out of ten perfect physics
love it
Skyrim the most flawless game of all
time yes why the hell not
it's stuff like this that makes games
fun I wouldn't want games to be too
polished whoa whoa and that's why you
don't do that that's why you don't throw
monitors here we go I want to see that
from that person's perspective Mario
Kart 5 really okay got the blue shell
there's a mark r5 whoa whoa call of duty
modern warfare flawless game nothing
wrong with it
10 out of 10 pretty pipe skiing on the
gun whoa
oh my god damn of course Korean of
course his name was Cheng ah when I
bought three 6000 ouch Betty uninstall
boy damn I love it though oh god no stop
it stop it link please
oh no it's nightmare fuel everywhere she
says that's kind of cool
whoa that's trippy as hell just an
everyday day everyday in the subway just
an everyday ordinary day so what I'm
trying to say Jesus Christ when
recalling is so strong it shatters
reality itself
[Music]
I can't look at this
stop read that in Redemption to cruel
world now I don't shoot the dog even
though it's a wolf
whoa yet again no mentors please no it's
the horse okay no oh cheese WWE here we
go oh no they're fine commentators
acting like nothing's wrong
do they fight trying to walk it up yeah
I'm fine I'm fine
Shadow the Colossus Oh No
damn I love this game should we play it
at some point
nice job impressive
[Laughter]
why would you do that oh my god
there's a glitch in real life we found
it finally glitch in real life sounds
like a funny man reddit normal Sunday
Drive okay
damn this looks good ah there's you just
hate when that happens
Jase it's the worst just the worst
Rainbow six flawless l cheese and that's
my friend is how different dimensions
look like I think I've seen this mama to
me no I kept my pasta there I dyed my
spaghetti meatball
oh no snot subnautica what happens here
who needs Rockets anyway whoa whoa this
will be an epic whoa epic time does he
keep going up
he's keep going up Jesus oh my god it's
not actually an planet cringe do they
all get stacked oh the new submarine I
love it damn oh they're not giving up oh
[ __ ] yeah that I get if Dennis was like
this every time come on so let's stop
that oh my god oh my god that's so funny
oh my god a good thing the ambulance is
there oh they're all dancing now
postal 2 flawless game P breaks the game
nice P physics I like it I like it a lot
[Music]
god dammit alright that's it for this
subreddit it's a really fun one thanks
to you for watching liking subscribing
supporting the channel I appreciate very
much thanks to everyone for checking out
the last of us live string it's been
really fun actually
no matter what your opinion is on the
game it's it's fun to share with you
guys and going through it so thanks for
joining those I try to scale it schedule
them out so you guys can try and catch
them and know what time I'm gonna be
live yeah I've been really fun doing
that in general just really enjoying
YouTube at this time so and I appreciate
have any audience just a random thanks
for no reason
thank you hey you haven't played super
simulator on the beach okay pack your
bags and sit down no one wants to see
your face mask tan lines anyway
download tuber simulator for the perfect
beach body